public sénat bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver sur public sénat encore
un rebondissement hier soir au sénat à
l'occasion de la nouvelle lecture du
projet de loi de finances pour 2013
la gauche sénatoriale a préféré faire
rejeter ce projet de budget en faisant
voter une motion de procédure pour
éviter que la droite ne fasse de
l'obstruction et empêche l'adoption de
ce texte dans les délais impartis par la
constitution alors dans un premier temps
la discussion générale avait commencé
tout à fait normalement avant une courte
suspension de séance ce matin retour sur
donc cette discussion mouvementée bonne
matinée à tous la séance est reprise et
nous passons la discussion de la
question préalable
monsieur françois rebsamen et les
membres du groupe socialiste et
apparentés ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 81 ans a
opposé la question préalable au texte en
discussion je passe la parole à monsieur
françois rebsamen pour la motion
tu vas bien
sur le seul président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il se passe
décidément toujours quelque chose au
sénat c'est donc maintenant ici au sénat
c'est sur le sénat que son braquer les
feux des projecteurs parce qu'à vous et
qu'il est quand même pour le moins
étrange
pour le président du principal groupe de
la majorité sénatoriale soutien affirmé
de longue date du président de la
république et du premier ministre
d'appeler le sénat a constaté que sont
la formule consacrée il n'y a pas lieu
de poursuivre la délibération sur le
projet de loi de finances pour 2013 soit
en réalité sur un texte etc sans
essentiels du gouvernement qui travaille
sous leur responsabilité
cependant je voudrais le dire d'entrée
cette décision bien sûr elle s'impose
non pas comme un désaveu du choix du
gouvernement que nous sénateurs
socialistes avant soutenu tout au long
des dernières semaines de discussions
budgétaires comme l'ont fait d'ailleurs
nos collègues députés
mais comme un refus mes chers collègues
comme un refus d artifice et un constat
de blocage
un refus d artifice d'abord car la
première lecture du projet de loi de
finances aurait dû aurait pu permettre
selon le calendrier prévu d'examiner
l'ensemble des crédits du budget général
de l'état sur la base des travaux de nos
rapporteurs spéciaux qui avaient
beaucoup travaillé et des rapporteur
pour avis c'était le mercredi 28
novembre ici même au soir et
j'interpellais
les collègues de l'opposition dont nous
connaissions le vote final pour leur
dire vous n'avez pas le droit
ainsi de laisser à part de ne pas
permettre le débat sur les missions vous
n'avez pas le droit de ne pas permettre
que tous nos collègues qui ont fait ce
travail de fond qui ont rapporté devant
leur commission ne puisse pas le faire
ici même au sénat en assemblée plénière
à rien en réalité à rien n'a été débattu
sur ces missions est donc un refus des
artistes disait mais aussi un constat de
blocage car l'absence d'accord sur le
contenu de la première partie a rendu
malheureusement impossible ce débat
laissons le soin à l'assemblée nationale
de prendre en compte un certain nombre
de préconisations des sénateurs qu'avait
formulée par ailleurs le président le
rapporteur général du budget certains
groupes certains groupes politiques qui
avaient exprimé leur désaccord tant sur
les dépenses que sur les recettes à et
qui avaient voté contre la première
partie on fait connaître tout
dernièrement en commission des finances
le souhait leur souhait de reprendre
aujourd'hui
la discussion sur l'ensemble du texte
par une abstention
j'appellerai une abstention blocage par
une abstention blocage sur la première
partie
pourquoi parce que tout le monde le sait
bien ce débat serait purement
artificielle les positions des
différents groupes sur les recettes ont
déjà été clairement exposées pendant les
travaux en commission ce qui condamne
d'avant les amendements qui pourraient
être présentées voir adopter leur
apportant général l'a rappelé si c'est
pour faire uniquement aujourd'hui du
théâtre ici au sénat dans le but dans le
but
mes chers collègues dans le but
d'empêcher le gouvernement de pouvoir
agir à travers sa loi de finance adopté
dans les temps
eh bien nous lisions opposons nous
opposants en outre la demande d'un
nouveau travail en commission des
finances exprimée par son président fait
peu de cas du travail réalisé tout au
long des mois d'octobre et de novembre
qui avait permis je le crois un certain
nombre d'avancées sur ce texte
pourquoi le reprendre lui dirais-je
aujourd'hui si celui mené pendant deux
mois ne le satisfaisait pas en réalité
le choix purement tactique de
l'opposition de s'abstenir
aujourd'hui et pas le 28 novembre de
s'abstenir
aujourd'hui sur la première partie afin
d'avoir une discussion sur l'ensemble du
texte aurait eu ses justifications
bien sûr en première lecture ce fut
d'ailleurs le choix de certains
sénateurs de l'opposition
mais si ceux là mêmes qui le demandent
aujourd'hui ne l'ont pas fait c'est
parce que il n'ya aucun doute aucun
doute sur votre démarche
certains dans l'explication de vote
qu'ils avaient donnés en première partie
je pense à notre collègue philippe adnot
déclaré qu'en s'abstenant
il n'en approuvait pas le fond du texte
de la loi de finances mais voulait je
cite permettre au sénat de jouer son
rôle tout son rôle d'analysé de
critiques et de proposer mission par
mission
le projet de budget présenté par le
gouvernement si aujourd'hui notre
collègue s'abstenait ce serait pour les
mêmes raisons et je soulignerai la
cohérence de la démarche que peuvent
avoir certains et la continuité des
choix même s'il ya des désaccords de
fond
en revanche il est impossible de trouver
des raisons valables à défendre pour la
première fois aujourd'hui cette position
à quelques jours à trois jours
à trois jours de la suspension des
travaux du sénat en particulier
s'agissant de ceux qui affirmait il ya
quelques semaines comme le président
marini lors de son explication de vote
sur la première partie je cite quelques
étés la qualité de l'appui dont nous
avons bénéficié de la part de nos
services
quelques étés la qualité de la
présidence ou des interventions de
monsieur le ministre
il va falloir que nous prenions nos
responsabilités cette responsabilité
était de voter contre
or au considérant qu'il faut aujourd'hui
reprend l'ensemble
l'ensemble de ces travaux je crois que
monsieur le président marini fuit ses
responsabilités institutionnelles et se
comportant en agitateur d'opposition en
agitateur d'opposition j'avoue cherchait
j'avoue chercher à excuser moi ça vous
cherchez sur le banc je vous sers c'est
sur le banc mais je sais que vous avez
très vite pris les habits de l'opposant
la cohérence la cohérence manque aussi à
nos collègues de l'ue dit qu'ils avaient
dans un premier temps j'avais cru
comprendre souhaité s'abstenir sur la
première partie puis avait décidé de
voter contre a séance publique avant de
revenir aujourd'hui à leur position
initiale
d'ailleurs c'est monsieur arthuis qui
avait dit je cite je ne veux pas voter
quotas première partie car j'estime que
le sénat une contribution essentielle à
apporter en matière d'économies de
dépenses qui viennent en discussion en
deuxième partie et ils le découvrent
aujourd'hui et ils le découvrent
aujourd'hui cette discussion n'a
finalement pas eu lieu parce que son
groupe a finalement décidé à la veille
du vote de voter contre
il n'est certes pas interdit de changer
d'avis mais quand cela porte sur le même
thème vous connaissez cette attache
juridique cet adage qu'il faut bien cité
en latin on peut le faire
ça plaira président marini mais il ya
beaucoup de latinistes sur les bancs de
la gauche n'est ce pas à moins cher que
la garder et bien pourra le dire
nemo auditur propriam turpitudinem
allegans et donc elle est bien sûr j'ai
pas voulu faire je n'ai pas voulu faire
pour ne pas être vexant des citations de
cour d'école
mais quand même quand même aujourd'hui
ne croyez vous pas que vous êtes un peu
l'hommage que le vix seront à la vertu
moi je le crois moi je le crois parce
que il y à une hypocrisie certaine dans
votre démarche cacher la démarche elle
est cachée ce que vous voulez c'est
empêcher que dans des délais
constitutionnels
le projet de loi de finances soit adopté
parce qu'il faut que tout soit terminé
vendredi vous le savez est donc je dis
aujourd'hui que vous êtes dans un esprit
d'agitateurs et d'opposants et de
blocages vis-à-vis de la démarche
sénatoriale qui est engagée ici aux
regards d'ailleurs de l'incohérence de
ses changements de positions successifs
il est évident que le seul objet d'un
examen intégrale du projet de loi par le
sénat n'a comme seul but que de retarder
son adoption de retarder son adoption
tout le monde l'a bien compris or le
retard le notre collègue arthuis est
évoqué tout à l'heure mais pour d'autres
raisons
le retard à six prix poserait une
difficulté constitutionnel réel
il ne s'agit pas que d'étudier les 21
amendements que vous annoncé vouloir
déposer des amendements de suppression
d'ailleurs que nous connaissons par
coeur il faudra entendre
il faudrait entendre il aurait fallu
entendre les rapporteurs spéciaux qui
avait fait un travail de fond
il fallait entendre quand il était temps
quand il était temps pour peser sur
l'assemblée nationale pour peser sur les
choix que nous défendions détendre
d'entendre aussi les rapporteur pour
avis or le retard pris aujourd'hui et
bien me renvoie tout simplement à
l'article 61 qui permet certes un examen
accéléré du texte par le conseil
constitutionnel mais impose de laisser à
celui ci un délai de huit jours une
adoption tardive du texte par le
parlement
empêcherait donc sa promulgation avant
le 31 décembre de la fin de l'année et
donc et donc et donc c'est arrivé à un
de vos collègues et la balle finit
d'ailleurs je me rappelle de raymond
barre qui avaient été confrontés à cette
difficulté majeure d'être obligé de
faire par ordonnance avouez que c'est
parce que vous voulez c'est parce que
nous souhaitons en tout les cas c'est
pas du tout ce que souhaite la majorité
sénatoriale la situation économique j'ai
entendu
le que les arguments tout à l'heure qui
mérite quand même d'être relevé la
situation économique impose une mise en
oeuvre rapide des priorités de justice
fiscale de justice sociale décidée par
la majorité à l'assemblée nationale
devant lequel le gouvernement est
responsable et chers collègues vous
pensez tactique
nous pensons aux français nous voulons
redresser notre pays
il en a bien besoin bien besoin
je cherche notre collègue de montgolfier
je sais pas où il est parti mais je
voudrais dire je voudrais lui dire il en
a bien besoin
ils devraient se rappeler l'état dans
lequel vous avez laissé notre pays
il y a à peine sept mois mais enfin un
peu de mémoire c'est vrai comme le
disait françois mitterrand quand la
gauche arrive au pouvoir
c'est la droite a mis le pays en
faillite c'est toujours comme ça que ça
se passe
c'était le cas en 80 le voilà c'était le
cas en 81
c'était le cas en 97 où vous pouviez pas
rentrer dans l'euro et c'est encore le
cas aujourd'hui
faut dire qu'aujourd'hui vous ne le
connaissez pas vous ne contestez pas
d'avoir laissé un pays en faillite
puisque vous l'avez même mis sur le dos
de vos prédécesseurs en 2007 vous aviez
déjà déclaré qu'il était en faillite
alors cinq ans plus tard avec votre
politique
c'était une grave faillite et c'est à
nous et c'est à nous d'y faire face
aujourd'hui et nous le faisons
voilà alors on va saluer les quelques
avancées grâce aux les mines entre avec
deux menées par notre rapporteur qui ont
pu être obtenues aller plus loin
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues seraient
vains en raison du rejet du texte
certains devant l'assemblée ce qui
laissera le dernier mot mais c'est ce
que vous avez souhaité depuis bien
longtemps
le dernier mot à l'assemblée nationale
question couleur politique cela ne nous
gêne pas nos collègues députés
soutiennent le gouvernement nous
soutenons aussi ce gouvernement et les
tests qui nous présente sur le reste je
renvoie à nouveau chacun à ses
responsabilités et à
l'incohérence j'espère que les groupes
de la majorité sénatoriale refuseront ce
qu'on peut appeler des manoeuvres
dilatoires irresponsable et j'appelle
d'ailleurs plus largement l'ensemble des
groupes à faire en sorte à l'avenir que
le temps parlementaire soit pleinement
utilisé lorsqu'il est disponible et pas
après et donc mes chers collègues en
application de l'article 44 alinéa 3 du
règlement du sénat
je vous demande mes chers collègues de
la majorité sénatoriale de voter cette
question préalable et de décider qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de poursuivre la
délibération sur le projet de loi de
finances 2013
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur marini contre
la motion monsieur le président madame
le ministre mes chers collègues
cette séance est vraiment surprenante
monsieur le président rebsamen
vous avez un certain temps siéger dans
l'opposition
avez-vous jamais voté en faveur de la
première partie de la loi de finances
présenté par des gouvernements que vous
combattiez avez vous jamais émis un vote
positif sur l'article d'équilibré étant
dans l'opposition
je ne crois pas je n'en ai pas le
souvenir mais reconnaissez que le rôle
de l'opposition la responsabilité de
l'opposition c'est d'argumenter pour
l'avenir et de contester ce qui lui
semble contestable dans les positions
défendues par le gouvernement
nous n'avons pas fait autre chose
maintenant si l'article d'équilibré en
première lecture a été
poussé par le sénat ce n'est pas dû à
l'opposition
vous vous est adressée à l'opposition
pendant votre intervention
mais l'opposition n'était en rien
responsable du rejet de l'article
d'équilibré
c'est un groupe qui se dit encore membre
de la majorité sénatoriale et qui en est
totalement responsable et vous le savez
monsieur le président rebsamen aussi
bien voire mieux que moi
alors maintenant vous essayer de
démontrer et notamment dans le
communiqué de presse que vous avez
transmis que nous nous livrerions à je
ne sais quelle manoeuvre
vous me qualifiez d'agitateurs de
l'opposition mais mais mais mais mais
avez vous regardé
avez vous regardé le nombre
d'amendements déposés
le groupe ump a déposé une vingtaine
d'amendements
le groupe crc qui appartient
théoriquement bien qu'ils votent contre
dans certains cas à la majorité
sénatoriale a voté lui a déposé lui
aussi une vingtaine d'amendements et
vous savez fort bien en parlementaire
rompu à la procédure parlementaire que
vous n'êtes que si l'on entrait dans
l'examen en nouvelle lecture
compte tenu du petit nombre
d'amendements et en même temps du fair
play qui existent au sénat qui est une
tradition de cette assemblée
mais vous savez fort bien que nous
pourrions venir à bout de cette seconde
lecture en deux journées de débats et il
n'y a aucune espèce de menaces à l'égard
du gouvernement et de sa capacité à
tenir les délais pour rendre la loi de
finances exécutoire bien entendu donc il
me semble que la manière sa manière
habile
et que vous avez utilisé est cependant
une ficelle un peu grosse
à la vérité à la vérité il y a une
grosse difficultés de coordination et de
cohérence de la majorité sénatoriale
actuellement c'est bien cela qui ressort
et qui vous contraint à cette contorsion
extraordinaire consistant pour le
principal groupe de la majorité à ne pas
vouloir examiner à ne pas vouloir
examiner le budget proposé par le
gouvernement que ce principal groupe
soutient ces c est quand même un très
singulier paradoxe à la vérité s'il y a
encore et vous en fait la démonstration
vous même ici s'il ya encore une
majorité au sénat
c'est une majorité négative enfin au
moins pour les textes économiques
financiers et fiscaux parce que pour
d'autres textes
le rapport
rapport est différent le rapport est
différent mais surtout les textes loin
de programmation des finances publiques
loi de finances loi de finances
rectificative et surtout les textes
essentiels loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale en matière économique
financière fiscale et concernant les
prélèvements obligatoires est bien le
gouvernement n'a plus de majorité
positives dans l'hémicycle du sénat
c'est ce que nous observons et vous même
fait usage différemment d'une majorité
négative que vous allez en effet pouvoir
obtenir sans doute sur le vote de la
question préalable ce qui est quand même
bien l'initiative négative par
excellence puisque visant à ne pas
examiner un texte que vous approuvez
mes chers collègues je crois qu'il est
inutile d'en ajouter beaucoup plus on
comprendra que le groupe ump et d'autres
groupes au sein de cette assemblée soit
prêt à faire l'exercice d'examen des
différents articles et je conclurai en
rappelant une raison de fond c'est le
fait que le gouvernement lui-même
introduit en nouvelle lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
un nombre important d'amendements en
particulier en ce qui concerne les
collectivités territoriales la
péréquation des ressources des
départements en effet est
substantiellement modifié par cette
initiative du gouvernement qui est
intervenu en nouvelle lecture à
l'assemblée nationale à la limite
monsieur le président rebsamen ne
pourrions nous pas convenir ensemble par
une sorte de gentlemen agreement 2
n'examiner que ces dispositions en
laissant passer toutes les autres
n'est-ce pas est ce que nous serions
susceptibles de faire
je prends à témoin mes collègues nous
n'abuse riom naturellement pas de la
situation mais cela supposerait que vous
retiriez en cet instant la motion visant
à opposer la question préalable
merci chers collègues je vais donc
demander l'avis de la commission
la parole est à monsieur le rapporteur
général merci le président je vais être
très bref la situation est simple
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
le plf après sa deuxième lecture et à
intégrer un certain nombre de nos
propositions
malheureusement elle n'a pas pu
véritablement intégré toutes les idées
que nous avions sur la deuxième partie
puisque la deuxième partie n'a pas pu
été évoquée au sénat nous avons perdu 13
journées de travail dans cet
enchaînement d'examen des lois de
finances et de l'ensemble des lois de
programmation depuis cet automne 13
journées de travail ont été perdus par
le fait que la première partie n'a pas
été votée ici au sénat c'est un constat
et face à ce constat on voit aujourd'hui
surgir un sentiment de remords de la
part de certains de nos collègues et
puis ce matin en commission nous disent
bon sang mais c'est bien sûr on appris
le le le la mauvaise décision
on aurait dû voter autrement on aurait
dû laisser le sénat travaille et en
totalité sur la première lecture et
ainsi être en capacité d'expliquer aux
députés et bien voici la vision du sénat
sur l'ensemble des textes l'ensemble des
articles en particulier tout ce qui
concerne les collectivités et nous
n'avons pas été en mesure de le faire
aussi fin que nous l'aurions souhaité ce
travail de pédagogie ce travail
d'explication alors j'entends bien ce
remords qui s'est exprimée en commission
ce matin et qui a conduit certains de
nos collègues de l'opposition à dire ben
finalement va changer notre point de vue
est maintenant on va se remettre au
travail dans les quelques heures qui
restent pour aller jusqu'à la fin de la
session budgétaire alors qu'on a perdu
13 journées on nous demande de reprendre
ce travail sur une centaine d'articles
en quelques heures
chers collègues connaîtrait que c'est
quelque chose qui est particulièrement
exigeant je pense que chacun ici pas
peur du travail que cela susciterait
mais je crains qu'il n'y ait
une objection majeure en effet si on
fait ce travail après tout on pourrait
s'accorder pour dire faut faire ce
travail ça n'aurait de sens que si ces
amendements étaient adoptés et en
l'occurrence si le projet de loi de
finances était adoptée dans cette
seconde lecture au sénat
parce que si le projet de loi de
finances n'est pas adoptée et
l'opposition nous a dit qu'il voulait
faire ce travail mais qu'il voulait
voter contre tout de même à la fin ça
veut dire ça veut dire monsieur monsieur
marini ça veut dire simplement que vous
demander de travailler pendant des
heures et des jours et des nuits en
complément ce qui a été fait mais que
vous nous dites de toute façon ce
travail on veut qu'il soit fait mais ça
ne servira à rien puisqu'on va voter
contre et qu'il n'y aura aucune
possibilité d'inscrire dans le projet de
loi pour 2013
tout ce travail qui aurait été fait ici
en jeu comprend pas la logique de 2,7
des marges monsieur le président je
comprends pas la logique consistant à a
assité à un travail tout en nous disant
d'emblée
eh bien on votera contre à la fin donc
je comprends bien qu'on est dans une
recherche de faire durer ce débat de
rechercher un blocage et de nuire au
gouvernement dans sa volonté d'aboutir
sur son projet de loi de finances est
d'empêcher le gouvernement d'agir au
plus vite pour redresser nos finances
publiques
restaurer la croissance et remettre le
pays d'aplomb c'est bien ça aujourd'hui
l'enjeu et c'est pour ça que nous avons
nous le souhait qu'il puisse agir au
plus vite et non pas de se satisfaire de
situation de blocage telle que celle qui
nous est proposé aujourd'hui je crains
qu il y ait un virus malfaisants qui se
sont un peu installé dans le paysage
politique français ces dernières
semaines celui qui consiste dans
certaines organisations politiques à
faire durer les palabres sans fin et à
faire des votes à faire des votes sans
fin je crains qu'il ne faille pas
accepter que le sénat se fasse inoculé
ce virus et que au contraire nous ayons
le sens de l'efficacité et que
nous opposions à la démarche qui est la
vôtre il faut voter cette motion c'est
l'avis de la commission et s'est
prononcé à 23 voix contre 13
c'est incontestable et donc c'est le
conte vendu que j'en fais à l'ensemble
de nos collègues en les incitant à voter
la motion défendue par françois rebsamen
merci monsieur le rapporteur général à
paroles l'état madame la ministre pour
avoir l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur le président je crois que le
président rap semaine a très clairement
dit les choses
la motion présentée répond à une
démarche d'obstruction c'est bien de ça
dont il s'agit qui vise à retarder
l'adoption d'un texte en prolongeant un
débat de manière stérile qui ne pourra
pas aboutir
le rapporteur général vient de le
rappeler donc cette notion elle est
nécessaire pour assurer une adoption
rapide de du projet de loi de finances
pour par le parlement dans les délais
constitutionnels donc son dépôt est un
acte de responsabilité et je remercie la
majorité de sénatoriales de le faire le
gouvernement apporte son soutien plein
et entier et donc cette motion doit être
votée j'ajoute que le rapporteur général
françois marque a rappelé tout à l'heure
dans la
dans le débat général que le sénat
malgré le rejet de l'ensemble a apporté
sa contribution soit qu'elles aient été
reprises à l'assemblée nationale dont il
a pris sa place toute sa place dans
l'élaboration de cette loi de finances
qui reprend nombre de ses propositions
c'est à la majorité de permettre la
promulgation de ce texte et surtout sa
mise en oeuvre
car nous pouvons vous pouvez avoir des
différences d'appréciation mais le sens
celui de la justice sociale et la
majorité sénatoriale le partage cet
objectif
merci madame la ministre nous en
arrivons donc aux explications de vote
je rappelle qu'il ya un représentant par
groupe
la parole est à monsieur l'abbé pour le
groupe écologique merci monsieur le
président ce président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
observé la gravité de ton du président
reds amman pour présenter ce moment qui
qui est qui et qui est très particulier
et c'est avec la même gravité que je
voudrais m'exprimer comme je les indices
qui indiquent est en discussion générale
malgré un certain nombre de réserves des
réserves qui se veulent constructives
parce que madame la ministre avec le
gouvernement avec la avec le groupe
majoritaire socialiste nous souhaitons
vivement discuté pour pouvoir avancer
ensemble
cependant groupe de la majorité nous
avons souhaité voter pour ce projet de
loi de finances en première lecture
toutefois le sénat a décidé de rejeter
la première partie de ce projet de loi
et conséquemment le projet tout entier
on peut bien sûr regretter que de ce
fait le film le sénat perdent
incontestablement de son influence dans
le processus de co construction de la
loi que nous menons avec l'assemblée il
en est il est en particulier
profondément dommageable que le sénat
n'ait pu se prononcer dans le cadre de
ce ps sur la question
les questions concernant les
collectivités tories territoriales qui
constitue
le coeur de sa compétence et à propos de
laquelle son expérience est aussi
reconnue qu'attendu néanmoins cette
décision du sénat à la conséquence des
choix politiques des uns et des autres
et cela il convient qu'on le respecte le
texte qui nous a présenté aujourd'hui en
seconde partie nous diffère de celui que
nous avons étudié en première lecture
qu'à la marge
or ce ne sont pas des détails qui ont
décidé les uns et les autres de se
prononcer sur ce texte comme l'
équilibre politique de notre chambre et
titan identique à celui qu'il était il
ya quelques jours à peine il va de soi
que les positions des différents groupes
politiques n'a pas changé or ce matin
donc j'ai appris puisque je n'y étais
pas et pour cause
nos collègues de l'opposition décidé
contre toute attente de s'abstenir sur
la première partie du projet de loi kill
fûtes qu'il fustige pourtant au seul
motif qu'ils souhaiteraient avoir
maintenant un débat sur la seconde
partie
j'ai écouté avec attention le président
marigny tout à l'heure qui nous a fait
un grand numéro d'acteur de théâtre est
pour le moment et je vais parler au
singulier un acteur de théâtre ou de
cinéma ne fait pas honneur à la france
alors nous n'allons pas imiter ce genre
de ce genre d'acte en or
alors alors que le droit aujourd'hui le
droit d'amendement est désormais
restreint à l'entonnoir
alors que l'assemblée a désormais
fortement imprimé sa marque sur ce texte
voilà vous sollicitez un débat devenu
impossible quelques jours seulement
après l'avoir refusée quand ils
pouvaient encore se tenir dans de bonnes
conditions
le regard que portent sur nous le peuple
français on doit-il faire attention
aujourd'hui cette c'est notre assemblée
qui ne sort pas grandi de ces petites
manoeuvres politiciennes et je vous le
dis il faut vraiment vraiment et je le
dis du fond du coeur que l'on fasse
attention au peuple français et que l'on
aille pas jouer des jeux je crois que ce
temps est fini on a discuté dans la
majorité parfois il peut arriver qu'une
majorité a besoin de se construire
eh bien on va la construire on aura à
discuter si c'est pour avancer et pour
avancer dans l'intérêt supérieur de la
nation et du peuple français
et c'est parce que le groupe écologiste
ne veut pas laisser notre institution se
faire instrumentaliser par une
opposition qui aujourd'hui se comportent
je suis désolé de le dire d'une manière
indigne c'est parce que nous souhaitons
que soient respectées les équilibres
politiques de notre chambre dans toute
leur diversité
et c'est aussi parce que nous
considérons que le départ
le débat parlementaire est une affaire
sérieuse que nous écologistes nous
voterons cette question préalable
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur de l'est et pour l'explication
de vote
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre et mes chers collègues
pour ma part moi je suis un jeune
sénateur je suis un petit peu surpris
par ces débats j'ai fait partie d'une
commission de ceux qui prenaient
l'abstention sur l'article d'équilibré
non pas que j'approuvais le budget mais
il me semblait que mon discours qui est
d'avoir des efforts beaucoup plus
importants sur les dépenses méritait que
l'on débatte de la seconde partie ici en
séance au sénat
et cette seconde partie sur l'émission j
avais beaucoup travaillé on a pas mal
d'amendements et il semblait qu'il était
souhaitable de pouvoir poursuivre et le
débat a eu lieu au sein du groupe u10
dont au sein du groupe u10 la majorité
du groupe a porté son choix sur le fait
de dire que je ne pouvais pas accepter
les augmentations d'impôts qui était
proposé dans cette première partie qui
était particulièrement forte puisque je
rappelle ces 20 milliards d'impôts qui
venait s'ajouter aux 7 milliards qui
avait été votée en juillet donc 27
milliards c'est vrai que c'est énorme
c'est à matraquage fiscal j'ai pas peur
du terme qui va qui va malheureusement
peser sur l'économie française et
accentuer les effets récessifs que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
et donc nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter
donc nous avons décidé de voter contre
ce qui nous a surpris c'est qu'il ya pas
de majorité au sein de ce sénat parce
que comme l'a dit le président marigny
tout à l'heure c'est pas nous c'est pas
à lui dit c'est pas l'ump qui ont fait
que ça que cette première partie n'a pas
été votée
c'est le groupe communiste qui a voté
avec nous contre cet article déquilibre
donc à partir de là effectivement n'a
pas pu discuter de la deuxième partie et
cette deuxième partie sur les dépenses
elle a été bien sûr examinés par nos
collègues députés qui ont modifié
certaines choses un peu à la marge la
jeu là vous mais à la marge sur les
collectivités territoriales et je pense
que nous pourrions nous entendre il
s'agit pas ici de vouloir un blocage de
l'institution et ni de faire une
bataille d'amendements et et d'arrière
garde je dirai simplement nous aimerions
pouvoir discuter d'un certain nombre de
points donc on peut s'engager ici si
vous retiriez 7
cette question préalable
pourrions nous engager à ne discuter que
de certains points est allé très vite
sur le reste et nous retirions nos
amendements ils sont pas très nombreux
on peut retirer ses amendements et faire
en sorte que l'on montre du sénat une
bonne image une image de gens sérieux
qui travaillent sur le fond et notamment
vis-à-vis de nos collectivités
territoriales je vous rappelle que nous
avons reçus des simulations qui sont
issus des décisions qui ont été prises à
l'assemblée nationale il ya quelques
minutes
donc on a à peine eu le temps de se
plonger dedans donc ça mérite qu'on
fasse un travail sérieux
pas la peine d'aller reprendre toutes
les missions et toutes les propositions
que nous aurions pu avoir en diminution
de dépenses sur l'émission mais que nous
travaillons sérieusement sur les
collectivités territoriales ça me
paraîtrait une bonne chose
donc moi je suis surpris de cette
question préalable qui viennent du
groupe qui soutient le gouvernement qui
va nous priver d'un débat qui me paraît
intéressant j'étais prêt à travailler
quelques heures quelques jours
supplémentaires
ici au sein de cette institution et je
pense que mes collègues mais aussi
donc tout cela étant dit je je pense que
vous avez conclu de vous-même que nous
voterons contre cette question préalable
et nous espérons qu'elle sera repoussée
merci chers collègues
la parole est à mme beaufils pour
explication de vote
monsieur le président madame et monsieur
le ministre chers collègues
j'observe que la procédure choisie par
le groupe socialiste n'est ni nouvelle
ni original un projet de loi
d'habilitation bien connu déposé à
l'automne 95 avait fait l'objet d'une
procédure identique en vue de pouvoir
entrer plus rapidement en application
nous sommes donc pas dans une situation
totalement inédite quand bien même ce
n'est pas le même type de texte puisque
à l'époque ce qui était en jeu c'était
les ordonnances juppé sur la sécurité
sociale ce qui quand même n'était pas un
mince sujet l'adoption de la motion
conduit donc à une conclusion plus
rapide des débats sur cette loi de
finances 2013
à tout le moins au sein de notre sénat
où le texte avait été rejeté suite à la
non adoption
je le rappelle de la partie recettes
mais son caractère éminemment défensif
ne doit pas faire oublier quelques-uns
des éléments essentiels du débat d'une
part une difficulté pour ne pas dire
plus du gouvernement et du ministère des
finances en particulier à faire preuve
nous semble-t-il de l'audace nécessaire
en ces temps difficiles pour conduire
une authentique réforme fiscale durable
et profondément progressiste s'inspirant
à la fois de ce qui fut accompli ici
l'an dernier et sachant faire la part
des choses
ce choix de réforme fiscale ne peut se
résumer selon nous par un partage du
poids de l'effort entre ménages
entreprises c'est bel et bien faire le
choix de mettre un terme aux inégalités
fiscales les plus évidentes et
uniquement celle ci la plus value mais
chers collègues je ne vous renvoie pas
ici à la lecture des grands classiques
c'est d'abord le produit du travail des
salariés avant d'être générés par
l'imagination débordante de
l'entrepreneur il est juste que son
éventuel fiscalisation reviennent au
bénéfice de tous c'est bien pour cela
qu'il ne fallait surtout pas céder aux
pigeons qui ont tenu la plume de bercy
sur l'article 6 nous pensons nous
pensons que ceux qui ont réalisé des
plus values importantes et bien souvent
vendre leurs activités avant qu'elle ne
soit avant qu'elle soit moins rentables
ne peuvent exiger d'être moins imposés
qu'un salarié dont les revenus auraient
progressé dans les mêmes proportions la
justice fiscale est un élément
indispensable de notre système de
prélèvements obligatoires
nous ne pouvons décidément accepter que
certains continuent sans que la moindre
preuve du bien fondé de la chose n'est
jamais été apportée à revendiquer une
baisse des dépenses publiques et vous
venez de le refaire à nouveau monsieur
de l'est pour retrouver l'équilibré
budgétaire exigé par le mécanisme
européen de stabilité qui avait été
votée dans cette assemblée sans notre
participation
vous savez combien les services publics
sont indispensables à la vie des plus
modestes
tout le monde a reconnu en 2008 que ces
dépenses publiques ses services publics
avait permis à la france de mieux passer
le cap que d'autres pays qui n'ont pas
ces outils à leur disposition
position il suffirait que vous renonciez
à l'un des aspects les plus discutables
du traité fondant l'union européenne
l'interdiction pour les états de l'union
de se refinancer auprès de la banque
centrale européenne pour que nous
puissions faire immédiatement l'économie
de plusieurs milliards d'euros
d'intérêts versés aux marchés financiers
en ramenant le coût apparent de la dette
publique au niveau du taux directeur de
la bce imaginé messieurs qui demandait
la deuxième lecture ce que serait une
dette de 1300 à 1400 milliards d'euros
supportant un coût moyen autour de 0,75
ou 1% d'intérêt au regard des 48
milliards d'euros que nous y consacrons
aujourd'hui aussi quand le groupe ump
veut nous proposer de discuter pour
présenter des amendements pour
soi-disant répondre au traité de
stabilité européen
j'aurais dû dire le groupe ump et le
groupe udi nous savons comme vous l'avez
déclaré bien souvent pendant les débats
que ce n'est pas le choix que vous ferez
quant à la dépense publique vous voulez
la réduire encore plus quand la
limitation de la création monétaire
n'empêche ni la récession économique ni
les dévaluation de fait il convient de
s'interroger
évidemment c'est compliqué quand on est
convaincus par quand on est partisan
convaincu de cette construction
européenne appuyée sur la concurrence
entre les pays et non sur la coopération
en même temps il est toujours plus
commun des facile de crier haro sur le
baudet fonctionnaires ou allocataires
social que de s'attaquer à la rente des
marchés financiers aussi l'abstention du
groupe ump envisagée sur les recettes
pour cette deuxième lecture ne serait en
rien liée à une amélioration du texte
dans le sens attendu par notre groupe
en tout état de cause nous voterons
cette question préalable
quand bien même nous étions parfaitement
disposés à examiner plus avant les
arguments invoqués par les uns et les
autres pour étayer leurs positions
notre présence d'ailleurs lors des
débats du plfr encore dernièrement alors
que sur d'autres banques les nombres et
être plus qu éclaircies
montre notre volonté de participer à ces
débats nous le voterons tout en ne
partageons pas le dernier alinéa de son
texte mais nous partageons le reste mais
nous le vôtre nous la voterons aussi
cette question parce qu'il convient d'en
appeler demain au dialogue nécessaire
tout simplement pour que la gauche
sénatoriale dans sa pluralité sa
diversité puisse pleinement se
retrouvait dans la politique de réussite
du changement attendu par nos
compatriotes pour construire la
politique de justice sociale et fiscale
à laquelle nous sommes particulièrement
attachés
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur de montgolfier
pour le groupe ump s'il me suis prêt
dans madame ministre monsieur ministre à
cette heure un peu tardive de la séance
prolongée je voudrais simplement en
répondant à quelques questions simples
vous redonner quelques chiffres tout
simplement première question y at il
encore une majorité dans ce scénario la
réponse nous l'avons eu
bah oui majorité négative la réponse
nous l'avons eue samedi avec le vote sur
une question importante le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité qui a été rejeté
par 203 voix contre 144 2 103 voix
contre 144
et ce vote explique peut être à lui seul
la question préalable de ce soir puisque
finalement jeu il semblerait que le
gouvernement ait peur de sa propre
majorité
alors sans doute alors j'ai entendu les
arguments des uns et des autres mais
notamment du présent arrêt de semaine
nous ferions de l'obstruction nouvelles
objections ore citant les chiffres à ces
dégâts il y a eu sur ce projet de loi 76
amendements déposés 76 amendements
déposés
c'est un nombre relativement raisonnable
vat 3 par le groupe ump 23 amendements
sur 76 est-il dans l'obstruction
non nous n'aurions déposé que des
amendements de suppression autre
argument nous aurions déposer des
amendements de suppression je voudrais
l'arrêté bien les chiffres nous avons
déposé 11 amendements de suppression
c'est vrai et 12 amendements purement
technique donc nous ne sommes pas
l'obstruction aux amendements de
suppression tout et pour tout
nous souhaiterions examiner la seconde
partie uniquement pour faire
d'obstruction
en seconde partie je vous rappelle que
nous n'avons déposé que deux amendements
le groupe ump et il ya en même temps des
amendements qui ont été déposées deux
par le rdse 4 par les rapporteurs
spéciaux notamment jean germain et
pierre jarlier monsieur patriat n'a
déposé pour le réduit à lui seul 3 donc
nous le groupe ump va déposer que 2 où l
obstruction et il faut rappeler que dans
le même temps à l'assemblée le
gouvernement a déposé
soixante trois amendements soixante
trois amendements en seconde lecture sur
le texte clairement où est la vérité qui
est raisonnable
voilà j'ai une proposition extrêmement
reza pour le coup et je pense qu'il
serait de nature à peut-être nous mettre
d'accord dans cette enceinte parce que
nous regrettons tous les uns et les
autres de ne pas pouvoir examiner
amendements techniques notamment
concernant les collectivités et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le groupe ump a
retiré tous ses amendements deux
premières parties tous ces amendes en
première partie et de ne s'être y ont
maintenant nous consacrer qu elle est
exclusivement que l'examen des
amendements de seconde partie concernant
les collectivités et en particulier aux
amendements de nos collègues germain et
j'ai rallié qui sont absolument
essentielles pour les départements je
crois que les conseils généraux les
collectivités que sont concernés nous
remercierai parce que la version qui est
issu de l'assemblée nationale est
catastrophique
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
position raisonnable on peut avoir fini
comme et président marini on peut avoir
fini à minuit en améliorer le texte est
concrètement je crois que ce sera
l'honneur du sénat voir des fois les
collectivités et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous faisons autre procès de
position je crois qu'on pourra y
souscrire
et dans ces conditions j'imagine que
peut-être le poste reviendra sur sa
position
merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur café pour
explication de vote
merci monsieur le président madame et
monsieur le ministre il est vrai qu'il
peut paraître insolite que un groupe de
la majorité
le principal des poses une question
préalable contre un texte qu'elle texte
puisqu'il s'agit de la loi de finances
du gouvernement qu'il soutient
ça n'est donc pas de gaieté de coeur que
nous voterons sa question préalable
et si nous le faisons mes chers
collègues c'est que notre objectif est
de préserver cette loi de finances est
de faire en sorte qu'elle s'applique
et si nous voulons que cette loi de
finances s'applique c'est parce que nous
sommes convaincus qu'elle sera utile aux
français que les crédits par exemple de
l'éducation que les crédits par exemple
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche que les crédits par exemple de
l'emploi notamment par exemple pour les
contrats d'avenir seront utiles aux
français si nous voulons que cette loi
de finances s'applique c'est que nous
sommes convaincus que la stratégie que
ce texte incarne est la bonne pour le
redressement du pays et que franchement
après avoir mené le pays je ne dirais
pas là bim met dans une situation dans
laquelle il se trouve
endetté à hauteur de 600 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires depuis cinq ans
avec un déficit du commerce extérieur de
70 milliards d'euros avec 700 mille
emplois détruits pendant cinq ans avec
cette situation là vous nous fait la
leçon aujourd'hui sur ce qu'il faudrait
faire
et sur la politique qu'il conviendrait
de mener eh bien non je le répète nous
avons véritablement l'intention que
cette loi de finances s'applique et ma
foi qu'elle soit adoptée par le sénat où
que finalement elle soit adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale
bien évidemment c'est regrettable
qu'elle ne soit pas adoptée par le sénat
et que nous ne puissions pas en discuter
notamment de la deuxième partie mais ce
qui nous importe à nous c'est le
redressement du pays
et de faire en sorte que les français
puissent bénéficier de cette loi de
finances et notamment j'ai parlé des
crédits et notamment renoué avec la
justice fiscale
parce que ils en ont bien besoin alors
nous sommes dans une situation où la
droite fait semblant de découvrir ce qui
s'est passé depuis que nous discutons on
nous dit aujourd'hui
ah bon ah mais ça c'est incroyable
mais on savait pas du tout en fait que
la première partie allait être rejetée
que les recettes n'allait pas être
adoptée a beau mais on ne savait pas du
tout que le budget ne serait pas
acceptée vous le saviez parfaitement
cela avait été énoncée dès la discussion
générale par les orateurs des groupes
vous connaissiez parfaitement de la
situation et vous avez pris vos
responsabilités en poney sens de cause
c'est à dire renoncer à discuter de
toutes les dépenses renoncer à discuter
de tous les crédits et renoncer à
discuter en particulier en particulier
vous renoncez cessé de matériaux
monsieur marini je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention et renoncer en
particulier à ceux qui fait peut-être la
spécificité du sénat c'est-à-dire
l'examen des collectivités territoriales
des dotations aux collectivités
territoriales des dotations de
péréquation et des mécanismes de
péréquation et maintenant vous constatez
évidemment un peu tard alors que ça vous
avez pris vos décisions en connaissance
de cause que l'assemblée nationale et
j'en conviens avec mon collègue gérard
miquel que l'assemblée nationale a pris
quelques décisions que nous aurions pu
amendé en réalité en réalité en réalité
le but que vous poursuivez n'est pas
celui là
le bund que vous poursuivez depuis
maintenant quelques heures après avoir
totalement changé d'avis changer d'avis
c'est de mener un débat de manière à ce
que nous sortions des délais
constitutionnels et excusez moi je vous
le dit nous ne prendrons jamais ce
risque nous ne prendrons jamais ce
risque parce que je le répète et ce sera
ma conclusion nous voulons que ce budget
s'applique
parce que nous voulons que la france
nous avec la justice sociale et nous
voulons que ce budget soit véritablement
le premier élément du redressement du
pays
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur collin pour le groupe rdse
oui rapidement le il est tard il est
surtout trop tard me semble-t-il pour
refaire le match j'ai eu l'occasion à
plusieurs reprises ici même j'ai eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises de dire
l'immense frustration de notre groupe de
ne pas avoir pu examiner la deuxième
partie du projet de loi de finances pour
2012 je ne vais pas y revenir ça a été
dit sur tous les bars et rappelé il est
bien dommage d'ailleurs et même
dommageable que le sénat n'est pas pu
suffisamment à enrichir ce texte et ce
dans l'intérêt de nos concitoyennes
aussi dans l'intérêt de notre
collectivité se vient encore d'être
d'être rappelé je crois aussi dans
l'intérêt de l'image de notes de notre
assemblée
aujourd'hui certains nous propose en
quelque sorte de revenir en arrière je
crois que cela n'est pas sérieux
nos équipes de collaborateurs depuis
quelques semaines depuis quelques mois
ont beaucoup travaillé ainsi qu aux
rapporteurs spéciaux qui avait préparé
l'examen des missions sécurité très très
utile bien sûr et nous ne sommes pas
prêts à l'évidence à nouveau marathon
si j'ose dire nous sommes un peu
fatigués même un peu émoussé donc je me
range très volontiers aux arguments
développés par fa soir rebsamen dans
présentant cette motion tendant à poser
la question préalable donc notre groupe
votera sans état d'âme cette motion
mettant un terme à ce psychodrame
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
je consulte donc le sénat sur la
question préalable opposé par monsieur
françois rebsamen et les membres du
groupe socialiste et apparentés et dont
l'adoption aurait pour effet d'entraîner
le rejet du texte en discussion
je vous rappelle donc que ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour la question
préalable remettront secrétaire un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre mais
trois bulletins bleus ce qui fait
s'abstenir remettront un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
non
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
on
résultat du scrutin numéro 73 sur la
motion tendant à opposer la question
préalable au projet de loi de finances
pour 2013 nombre de votants 346 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 346 majorité
absolue des suffrages exprimés
174 pour l'adoption 177 contre 169
le sénat a adopté la question préalable
voilà pour l'adoption de cette motion de
procédure qui je vous le rappelle a donc
empêché à l'adoption de ce projet de loi
de finances pour 2013 qui était examiné
au sénat en seconde lecture le texte va
donc très rapidement retourner à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui pour
une adoption définitive du premier
budget du quinquennat de françois
hollande très belle journée à tous